here's another thing that you did last
thing
but um i don't know if you remember this
but we were doing harold and kumar
three
uh do you remember
the the uh
medic
the the guy that did the
i know i cuz that was so funny because
i um
brought it up before you got here i
don't feel remember this but
so do you remember so what happened was
i asked for like an aspirin
or something yeah to the medic
you wanted because i think your trailer
was farther away so you wanted to use my
restroom for some reason
so you went in there he came around the
corner
this medic
and he goes oh mystery
hell yo i be propane or whatever yeah
and i'm on a movie set
i don't you know i'm so desperate to be
there right so i don't want to cause any
waves so i'm like
oh hi i guess
i'm mr ree
yeah he comes out and he goes looks at
the [ __ ] medic it goes don't ever do
that again
damn
and i went
oh my god he's my hero
because you did something that i
have always wanted to do
but because i was conditioned
to
play along
right with white people when they do
these things that they think they're
being so [ __ ] funny
and i don't want to be confrontational
so i just let it go and i think that
that's the wrong move
i uh remember that and um i also
remember thinking because i i'd never
asked for anyone to be fired
and i and i had a discussion i went back
and
i think i think i talked to john and
hayden about it and and we and i talked
about it
one
now as i'm recalling i think part of
why i didn't press the issue was
he was from europe
um
and they got they they got some weird
sensibilities
really yeah
throw bananas on the soccer field at
black players yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's bananas over there and so
literally
funny and so i i remember going okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna step back and and just
let him know that
this isn't going to be tolerated but
yeah i was kind of surprised myself i
was like i got really pissed yeah i was
like
what are you doing yeah it was really
like crazy the way he did it like
full-on like he did the walk
he did the whole like he did that whole
walk with this thing no yeah yeah he
kind of went around the corner oh dude
you didn't tell me that at the time
he would have been fired no but he did
the whole thing and like i would have
let it go but you you know and from i
don't think from then on when people do
that i think i say [ __ ] now okay hey
dude that's 80s yeah like at a comedy
club i'll get off people go mister
ryusopani i got dude
bro what are you doing yeah but before i
never said anything i said that's great
white people are crazy i just had this
uh i read the script recently
and um
there was a
asian joke in it
in the scene and i was like why does
this bother me
and the in the the joke was meant to
cast this character the other character
as an [ __ ]
okay uh-huh
and it was directed towards me or my
character they're the one i'm being
asked to play
and uh
and i just i was reading it today and i
was like oh i think